should I reveal what really happened
that night 13 years ago we know it
wasn't easy having to fight Voldemort
Harry the guy was after your whole life
it was his fault that your parents were
gone and you had to be raised by the
mean Dursleys and you could have had way
more fun at Hogwarts if Voldemort wasn't
always trying to attack you but have you
ever considered that maybe Voldemort got
the prophecy wrong we first learned
about the chosen one prophecy in order
of the Phoenix but what if he reaches in
one keep watching to find out all the
reasons Harry isn't the one Voldemort
needed to go after the famous prophecy
from Harry Potter was told by Sybill
Trelawney professor Trelawney usually
just made up all of her divinations but
occasionally she slipped into a trance
and told the future for real one of
these times was when Dumbledore was
interviewing her for the divination job
she gave her prophecy about who could
defeat Voldemort Severus Snape overheard
only part of it and went to tell
Voldemort but the prophecy could have
been about two different boys we're
going to look at the prophecy line by
line to prove that maybe Harry wasn't
the chosen one the first line of the
prophecy says this just means that at
the time that she gave the prophecy the
one with the power to take on Voldemort
hadn't been born yet that wasn't great
news for the people who were fighting
the first Wizarding war
Trelawney continues to say that this kid
will be born to those who have thrice
defied him born as the seventh month
dies this first part is still pretty
vague the parents have to have defied
Voldemort on three separate occasions
here's what isn't clear though did each
parent have to defy Voldemort three
times is it a combination of the times
that they defied him or did they have to
fight and if I hand three times together
that's the thing with magical prophecies
they're never super clear but what is
clear is that however Voldemort was
divided the parents were currently
expecting a baby and this baby has to be
born as the seventh month dies that
means the end of July with these two
criteria
Voldemort figures out that the baby
belongs to either the Potters or the
bottom's both the potters and the
Longbottom's had been fighting Voldemort
and the Death Eaters
they were both members of the original
order of the Phoenix as parents they
suffered of death there is no specific
birthdate mentioned either the baby just
had to be born at the end of July Mary
was born on July 31st and Neville was
born on July 30th we know that Voldemort
wanted to try to get rid of both he sent
his most trusted followers after the
Longbottom's Bellatrix Lestrange and her
husband ro Dolphus along with Rob Astin
Lestrange and Barty Crouch jr. were who
he picked these four wicked Death Eaters
used the curse until Frank and Alice
Longbottom went insane they never got to
Neville though bull de mort himself went
after Harry Snape had begged him not to
kill Lily but Lily chose to defy
Voldemort again and gave her life to
Harry her love made the avada kedavra
curse backfire and destroy Voldemort
soul I could not touch this is where
things get messy with the prophecy now
lily has defied Voldemort a fourth time
that means she has no longer thrice
defied him the next line of the prophecy
says the Dark Lord will mark him as his
equal but he will have the powers the
Dark Lord knows not some people think to
mark him as his equal means Harry
scarred the prophecies aren't that
literal he sent his most trusted
follower after the Longbottom's which
could mean he thought that they were an
equal threat and he could have chosen to
go after Harry himself because they were
both half-bloods both Neville and Harry
have powers that Voldemort doesn't know
about Mary is protected by his mother's
love but Neville is gifted the sword of
Godric Gryffindor from the Sorting Hat
this is how he defeats Nagini which
destroys the final Horcrux the equality
part could come from being essentially
orphans Harry and Voldemort both lost
their parents young Neville's parents
were lost too they may be alive but he
had to be raised by his grandmother it
could also come from being chosen by the
founders of their houses Voldemort was
the heir of Slytherin and had the power
to talk to snakes
both Neville and Harry were chosen to
wield the Gryphon
door sward on different occasions
Voldemort might have marked both of them
as his equal the next part of the
prophecy makes more sense than the rest
it says either must die at the hand of
the other so Voldemort or the chosen one
must kill the other and neither can live
while the other survives then Trelawney
repeats herself about when the chosen
one will be born older more technically
kills Harry but that is what gets rid of
the Horcrux inside him but there is
still one Horcrux left
Voldemort cannot be defeated without
killing Nagini first that's what Neville
does that allows Voldemort to die by a
weird connection in their wands Harry
only cast a disarming spell he didn't
really kill him
testing expel Aramis doesn't end
people's lives by cutting off the
Keeney's head Neville is the one who is
responsible for defeating Voldemort some
people say that either Neville or Harry
could have been the chosen one by going
after Harry himself
Voldemort made Harry the chosen one but
the prophecy was clearly talking about
one boy there is just a lot of evidence
that Voldemort chose wrong who do you
think the prophecy was talking about let
us know in the comments the boy who live
how about your legendary thanks for
watching click the subscribe button for
more awesome content from the things and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up we'll see you next time
[Music]